what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
really really big news about the X-Men
in the MCU and I am specifically talking
about the X-Men team not individual
mutants but the team it looks like the
mutants and the X-Men could be hitting
the MCU a lot sooner than we thought yes
Kamala Khan is a mutant in the MCU now
and technically she is the first one but
it looks like mutants may have already
been existing in our main MCU Universe
for a while now and it looks like
technically Wanda could have been the
first mutant introduced into the MCU
they hinted at this in one division
which I'll talk about but right now it
looks like the X-Men team could have
already been established Insider MCU
with some Classic X-Men as a part of
that team of course led by Professor
Xavier now this is actually coming from
an Easter egg that was supposed to be in
Miss Marvel some unused concept art from
Avengers Con in the first episode of
Miss Marvel has been released and it
gives us a picture of Psy Cyclops
specifically somebody dressed up in
Cosplay as Cyclops now right away the
reason that this Easter egg is so big is
the same reason that they actually
didn't show this in the first episode or
in the series at all the second we would
have seen this in the very first episode
we would have gone that is a person
dressed up as Cyclops which means
Cyclops is an actual hero in the MCU
which means mutants actually exist in
the MCU we would have caught that right
away we would have known about the
mutants and we would have known that
there is somewhat of an X-Men team in
the MCU and that would have spoiled the
big ending where they say that Kamala is
a mutant so of course they left that out
because it would have spoiled the ending
however we now have the concept art that
shows somebody dressed up as Cyclops and
it means the exact same thing if
somebody was going to cosplay a cyclops
that means that Cyclops is real which
means that Kamala Khan is not the first
mutant in the MCU in fact there could be
many many more mutants in the MCU that
already exists that we simply haven't
been introduced to yet and it looks like
the X-Men team could have already been
established inside of the MCU as well
based off of the costume that this
cosplayer is wearing if you take a look
at the photo you can clearly see the
cosplayer that is dressed up as Cyclops
has an X-Men logo on his chest that
would confirm that the X-Men team does
exist because if he was just dressing up
as Cyclops who was a Lone Hero a mutant
who was not a part of an X-Men team he
simply wouldn't have the X-Men logo but
he does have the X-Men logo on his chest
which means the team does exist and
cyclops is a part of that team which
makes me really really excited because
Cyclops is such a classic mutant A
Classic X-Men and I was worried that
Marvel Studios in order to kind of
differentiate themselves from Fox's
X-Men weren't going to use any of the
iconic X-Men that they used over in the
fox universe but this would seemingly
confirm that Cyclops will be in the MCU
and already does exist in the MCU and
this actually comes at a very
interesting time because we've recently
heard some casting news about Cyclops in
the MCU and this is coming directly from
the actor Taryn egerton who everybody
wants to play Wolverine and there's some
good news to that he has actually met
with Marvel Studios and he's recently
talked on a talk show about how he was
talking with Kevin feige about playing
Cyclops check out what he had to say is
that true that I I yeah I don't mind
saying that was that was a real thing
there was a real conversation and um
to be honest I've never said this
actually to be honest the reason that
conversation never went any further is
because I I don't I didn't want to I
didn't want to play a character for a
potential of a series of movies okay
where you don't see my eyes for me that
that's I I didn't I felt instinctively
creatively that that like the eyes of
the windows to the soul I don't know how
I would find that challenging and I just
didn't find it an intriguing Prospect so
if it's not that they ever offered it to
me but there was a conversation a real
conversation that never went any further
wow I respect so right there on the
Sirius XM show Sway in the Morning Taryn
egerton says I don't mind saying it that
was a real thing that was a real
conversation when talking about meeting
with Marvel Studios about playing
Cyclops now they went on to ask him
about him playing Wolverine in the MCU
because that's been a lot of talk
recently fans really want him to play
Wolverine and some reports have said
that he is based on the fact that he had
met with Marvel and he addresses this
but more importantly he confirms one
thing he says I made the mistake of
saying that I had a general meeting with
Marvel around four years ago ago which
is true here's why this is important now
he says it was a mistake because he said
it and everybody thought he was going to
be playing Wolverine however as he
explained it was about Cyclops and the
important part that is revealed here is
that he met with Marvel Studios four
years ago that was a very long time ago
and that means Marvel Studios has been
planning for the X-Men for a long time
now for at least four years and that was
right around the time where the fox
Disney deal was done I know there's been
a lot of talk recently about some type
of a contract between Fox actors or Fox
Executives and Marvel still not being
able to use the X-Men in the MCU however
we don't really know if that's true or
not so I wouldn't accept it as true yet
especially since Marvel Studios met with
Taryn egerton four years ago about
playing Cyclops and also not to mention
the Fantastic Four were a fox property
they now belong to Disney and they've
already recast Mr Fantastic with John
Krasinski and Multiverse of Madness so
right now I'm actually going to assume
that Marvel Studios can use the X-Men
whenever they want in the MCU and this
is where things get really really
exciting concerning the X-Men like I
mentioned the Cyclops X-men Easter egg
this person cosplaying as Cyclops a
member of the X-Men that was never put
into the first episode seemingly
confirms that the team does exist which
means the team most likely has a leader
and if it's an X-Men team then it is
most likely led by Professor Xavier
Professor X which means that Professor
Xavier's School for gifted youngsters
probably exists in the MCU and if you
know anything at all about Professor
Xavier you know that Professor X seeks
out mutants and as far as I'm concerned
right now we've been introduced to two
mutants in the MCU and are about to be
introduced to one more The Two Of course
being Kamala Khan and the Scarlet Witch
now Marvel Studios didn't Straight Up
come out and confirm that Wanda is a
mutant but they also kind of did in
episode 8 of Wanda Vision I got the
Harkness commented how Wanda's exposure
to the Mind Stone Amplified something
that was inside of her already in
episode eight she specifically says and
I quote Little Orphan Wanda got up close
and personal with an infinity stone that
Amplified what otherwise would have died
on the vine end quote now it seems like
based off of what we've seen in Miss
Marvel if you have an X Gene in the MCU
it needs to be awoken now I know this
sounds very similar to the Inhumans but
Marvel kind of made it clear right now
that the Inhumans aren't going to be in
the MCU and if they are they're not
going to be kind of how they originally
were and it could be that Wanda has the
X Gene and it was awoken by the Mind
Stone what Agatha Harkness says
seemingly hints that Wanda is a mutant
so technically if this is true Wanda
would be the first mutant in the MCU
plus there's still a lot of Wanda's
backstory that we don't really know
about and there have been rumors that we
are going to be getting a true solo
Scarlet Witch movie if so and that is
true I do hope they Explore her mutant
background and then of course we have
another mutant coming up which is Namor
Namor the Submariner often given the
nickname Marvel's first mutant is making
his debut in in Black Panther wakanda
forever now he is a mutant in the comics
at least half mutant half Atlantean and
it looks like that's going to be the
same in Black Panther we have a scene
underwater that shows him being born and
if you take a look at the baby the baby
has wings on his feet just like Neymar
in the comics which would seemingly
confirm that he is indeed a mutant also
note that Neymar does not have blue skin
in the trailer while all of the other
atlanteans do this is also because he is
half Atlantean not full so hopefully
Marvel Studio sticks true to Neymar's
backstory and they keep him a mutant
especially since they introduce Kamala
Khan as one now like I mentioned
Professor X likes to go look for mutants
and since it looks like the X-Men team
exists in the MCU now I would not be
surprised if Professor X goes looking
for Kamala Khan then shortly after Namor
if he hasn't already actually tried to
get Neymar already and I also believe
that since we got Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness and we saw the
Fantastic Four the X-Men and other
characters Dr Strange can only go so
long until he actually searches for the
those people in his own Universe if it
were me and I ran into this extremely
powerful team although it doesn't really
seem like that based on their fight with
Wanda but they are a truly powerful team
if I ran into this team in Another
Universe and they were the main
superhero team I would look for those
people in my own universe so I'm
thinking it's only a matter of time
until we actually see doctor strange go
seek out this people perhaps that's how
some of these mutants and other
characters could be introduced into the
MCU since this concept art seems to make
it pretty clear that an X-Men team
already does exist which is huge news
and since d23 is right around the corner
about a month away let's hope that one
of those face slick slots is for the
mutants maybe it's an X-Men movie maybe
it's about mutants before they join the
X-Men but let's hope it's about mutants
in some way shape or form that way they
can all be a part of Secret Wars but
mutants are now officially in the MCU
and things are really really exciting
let me know how excited you are about
the mutants and the MCU in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and subscribe if you want to
stay up to date on all things MCU for
live updates you can follow follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf